Another year without the postseason…
Dear God, or the Dalai Lama or whatever,
I don’t know, I’m still searching-
Please show me the way.
JORDY NELSON?!
Now I hope you weren’t trying to tank.
Tanking’s a sin.
No, but sometimes I wish
I was just never even drafted at all.
That’s an idea.
What do you think, Vince Lombardi?
OK. I agree.
You’ve never been drafted.
Hey, my leg stopped hurting-
What.
I’m 49 years old
and I’m still the quarterback of the Packers.
Without you, Brett Favre wouldn’t leave.
The Packers haven’t won a game in 10 years.
State Farm shut down.
Nobody was here to discount double check.
The Bears won that 2010 NFC championship.
I’m Jay Cutler, and I never give up.
Clay! Clay, don’t you know me?
HELP! THIS MAN IS SCARING ME!
JORDY! GET ME BACK.
I want to be on the Packers again!
Hey Aaron-
Hey, watch your-
MY LEG’S HURTING, BRETT!
MY LEG’S HURTING!
MERRY CHRISTMAS GREEN BAY!
Aaron!
The owner’s going to make changes!
We are going to hire someone
with imaginative play-calling!
Every time a whistle blows
the Packers still have
more rings than the Bears.